Hey,
just before we get cracking
with today's video,
I got to say there's a lot of
Russian pronunciations in here.
I am looking them up when I can,
but I don't always get them
a hundred percent right.
I apologize ahead of time if
you want to have a go at me.
Well,
that's what the comments are for.
Right.
Okay.
Let's crack on.
During the Bolshevik revolution,
the Romanov Dynasty was killed off
to over a 100 year reign of Russia.
The bodies of the parents and all five
children were laid out on the grounds,
but when the corpses were later
moved and given a proper burial,
the bodies of the sun,
Alexi and the Princess Anastasia,
we're missing this,
gave the Russian people hope that at
least two of these innocent children
managed to play dead long
enough in order to escape.
Several years later,
a young woman was admitted to
a mental hospital in Germany.
There were skulls all over her body
and she clearly suffered some traumatic
events,
but her mind to block
out the painful memories.
She couldn't even remember her name.
The only clue about where she came
from was the fact that she spoke with a
Russian accent.
Months later,
a Russian patient was admitted to that
same hospital and she immediately began
to kneel in front of this young girl.
She claims that she recognized her
as the missing Princess Anastasia,
but who was this young woman?
Was she really the long lost princess
or would this go down as one of the
biggest frauds in all of history?
Anastasia Romanov was born in 19.
Oh,
one,
two saw Nicholas.
The second one,
his wife saw rina,
Alexandra theater,
rovner.
I propertycapsule it
was grand duchess best.
No one ever addressed the young girl
with this proper title in her daily life.
She had three older sisters,
Olga,
Maria,
and Tatiana.
Her younger brother,
Alexia was meant to ascend
to the throne someday.
The Romanov children were the first royals
to have such an extensive collection
of family photographs.
There are hundreds of pictures and
videos of their family vacations and them
playing games on the palace grounds.
It was easy to see that
they live a carefree life.
Their pictures were publicized all over
Russia and they became the darlings of
the country.
Anastasia was an extremely energetic
toddler who had a bubbly personality.
She was very intelligent,
so she grew bored of our
tutors lessons very quickly.
She was a tomboy and she enjoyed playing
outside far more than doing ladylike
activities with her sisters.
She was described as clumsy and was
always climbing on something or running
around somewhere.
She seemed to have an endless amounts of
energy according to some of our cousins
and ladies in waiting Anastasia's board
and manifested in some terrible ways.
She would entertain herself by playing
pranks on people and to our cousins
called evil.
In one of the servants'
quarter a terrorist,
she tripped on a servants in the hallway,
climbed up trees,
and refused to come down and
hit rocks inside of snowballs.
She would often cheat during games and
she lied a lot to get herself out of
trouble.
At one sign,
a monk named gregory rest.
Pinkston became the spiritual
advisor of the Romanov family.
Sorry,
Inner Alexandra.
I whole heartedly that he had
magical powers that heals,
had a son,
Alexi,
who was suffering from
hemophilia respiration,
was able to heal him from the
brink of death because of this,
she listened to his advice and gave
him free rein in the royal palace,
Anastasia,
that may or may not have realized it,
but her father Nicholas had a problem
with drugs and one of his diary entries he
wrote about waking up with a stuffy
nose and planning to fix it by snorting
cocaine.
Back then,
the cocaine was actually prescribed
by doctors as medications,
so it didn't hold the same
stigma that it does today.
While she did not take recreational drugs.
So arena Alexandra,
it was described as being
anxious and high strung.
Anastasia commented that her mother
barely ever indulged in coffee or wine
because she had a bad stomach.
She was also incredibly spiritual and
often went to mistakes to help make
decisions about day to day life.
Rasputin was also pretty
famous for using morphine,
cocaine,
and opium on a regular basis.
Some historians believe that the
closer he got to the SAR and Sarina,
the more the couple became dependent on
the drugs and guidance of the fanatical
religion that Rasputin was introducing
them to after witnessing the terrible
things that drugs did to
the adults in her life.
Anastasia became obsessed with
clean eating and natural remedies.
She spoke against drug use
and became a vegetarian.
Every time she was sick,
she would throw a fit,
refusing to take any medication because
she didn't want to be like Rasputin into
father.
Sevens noted that Rasputin was given a
little too much access to the children in
1910.
One of the Nannies was particularly
disturbed about the fact that the monk was
often witnessed with four girls
when they were in their nightgowns.
He had the freedom to enter the
children's nursery whenever he wanted.
That same year.
One of the other governesses
claims that Rasputin raped her.
She tried to tell the Sarina,
but sadly the Sarina was so brainwashed
by recipes in that she refused to
believe the government asked the girls.
They were growing older.
The eldest daughters were
already teenagers and
Anastasia was nine years old.
One of the other servants
believed the governor,
the story about the rape,
the parents of the children who have
flaunting preoccupied with their own
issues,
so this only trying to keep
[inaudible] away from the children.
The girls were very naive and did not
see any issue with him coming to visit
them at night.
They called him a friends and when they
told Sardina Alexandra that the nanny
was trying to keep them out
of the nursery at night.
She was fired according to the
children in was simply visiting,
do tell them bedtime stories and help
them say that press back in his hometown,
Ras and actually did
have children of his own,
so it's always possible that he
was acting on fatherly instinct,
but its reputation of being a sexual
deviance would be enough for anyone to be
worried.
After the nanny was fired,
she told everyone she
knew about the story.
This box of remit,
that respite and had free reign to visit
the princesses at night in a sexual
way.
There is no evidence that rescues and
ever actually abused the Romanov children,
but of course we'll never really know
what happens behind closed doors.
However,
it was around this time that saw Nicholas
ordered Rasputin to leave some in
Petersburg when world war one first began.
Anastasia was only 13 years old.
Her mother and sisters were old enough
to volunteer as nurses for the Red Cross.
She did her duty by playing pool and
chest with the soldiers and entertained
people with our wild energy
and Loftin as a teenager.
Anastasia used her acting talents for
good though what seems like mean spirited.
Pranks that she played in her childhood
actually ended up being loved comedy.
Her family and members of the staff
would often put on their own plays and
performances.
According to witnesses,
Anastasia was naturally hilarious and
did everyone laughing so hard that they
had peers in their eyes.
Sometimes she would burst out funny faces
when the camera was trying to capture
a candid moment of her sisters
in every difficult situation.
Anastasia was always the one to fix
it and always the one to make everyone
around us smile.
Now,
after the war,
Russia began suffering
a terrible depression.
People were starving,
men had died during the war and
people desperately needed help.
Many people viewed the royal family
as being part of the problem,
their reputation for bad decision making
with Rasputin session that he didn't
tell Eva,
and basically the short of it is the
communism took hold by the time Anastasia
10,
16,
the Romanov family was placed under
house arrest by the Bolsheviks.
The criminal family were ordered to leave.
Their costs were put under house arrest.
They will move from place to place,
and their last residence was
a place called Patty of house.
Even in these dark moments,
Anastasia was still trying to
make everyone laugh and smile.
It was noted that she adjusted the
best to that new life of captivity.
One of the guards told a story of
Anastasia trying to open a window for some
fresh air and they shot at her to
keep her from trying to escape.
She turned to the guard and stuck her
tongue out Sam's window shut and walked
away.
Even in this awful situation for her,
she was fearless at first.
Lennon wrote,
the family was in captivity and
promised that they were still alive.
However,
he soon realized that as long as
the role deadlines still existed,
that would always be a chance
that soldiers loyal to the Roman,
obviously we'll try to overthrow him.
He decided that the only way for communism
to exist was to execute the entire
family.
The family was made to walk down to
the basement where a group of men were
ordered to shoot at them.
During the execution,
the gunman realized that the daughters
were still alive even after being shot
multiple times in the chest.
It turns out they were wearing corsets
that had been lined with Raul gemstones
and this acted like a bulletproof vest.
After this,
each of the family members received a
shot to the head to ensure that they
actually did die.
However,
some believe that these gen line course,
it would've been enough for the gunmen
to hesitate to kill the two youngest
members of the family.
At this point,
it's all of the older daughters
were full grown women,
but Anastasia and Alexa were
only 13 and 16 years old.
They weren't innocent children
and they didn't deserve to die.
Many people hopes that the
gods took pity on them.
One of the men in the firing squad,
Rudolph Laka,
was originally from Austria and he was
staying in as a prisoner of war as a
foreigner.
He had no loyalty to the imperial
family and was ordered to serve the
bolsheviks.
He claimed that he pulled over the
truck when I got stuck in the mud,
he could hear a rustling in the back
and when he went to check on the bodies,
he discovered that
Anastasia was still alive,
I think helped her escape.
However,
there were other quotes from her that
indicated the total opposite was true.
He was one square to to saying that he
didn't care about killing the Romanov
family.
They weren't relatives of his and he
was doing his duty for the Bolsheviks,
but this confession was enough to spawn
remiss that Anastasia had actually
escaped.
In 19,
20,
a young woman in Berlin,
Germany attempted to jump off a
bridge and commit suicide nearby.
Police officers saved her life and
brought her to a mental hospital for
treatments.
She was beautiful and spoke
with a thick Russian accent.
When the doctors disaster who she was,
she replied that she didn't know
there were scars all over our body,
including a triangle shaped indentation
in how foot and deep lacerations on her
back.
It was clear that she had survived
some sort of horrific trauma and brain
completely shut down.
Every night she would wake up
screaming to her nightmares,
the memories.
They were simply too painful for
her to recall when she was awake,
but at night they seem to come to her.
The doctors gave her the nickname of miss.
Unknown.
Two years later,
this unknown,
we're still living in a mental hospital
in Germany when it Russian women was
admitted as a patient.
The woman was shocked and immediately
kneels in front of the young women.
She said that this was the
missing princess on a stage up.
Ms Dot unknown did not
confirm or deny the statement.
She had no idea who she actually
wasn't becoming a princess.
Sounded pretty fine to her.
So the doctor has.
This actually needs a lot of sense though.
Ms Dot unknown had clearly
endured something horrific
and it was the answer to a
mystery.
They had long been trying to solve,
comparing photos of both misson known
and Anastasia next to one another.
It is easy to see why many
people believe this to be true.
They have the same.
His nose and dies.
Ms Dot unknown was also the same age.
In 1922 newspapers began to claim that
the princess had been found and her photo
was published.
Friends and family of the Roman.
This came from all over
the world to visit her.
They would ask her questions
that only Anastasia would know,
and yet somehow this woman knew many of
the answers the opinion of friends and
family was divided.
Fifty slash 50.
While the case was under investigation,
she was invited to stay in castles with
Rehmann off cousins and several people
to send money to her to help her pay
for our expenses and is tier to Sydney.
Gibbs was one of the
most outspoken critics,
though he vividly remembered
his student's personality,
no matter how much they look the same.
This woman liked Anastasia's
whips onto a sense of humor.
Another tutor pr guerrilla agreed.
They found the tree princess first.
However,
once he spent more time around this woman,
he agreed that they were
not the same person.
She was soft spoken and ladylike,
but relatives who only saw her
when she was on her best behavior.
It was easy to imagine that
she could be Anastasia,
but for people who knew
what she was really like,
this was an entirely different passenger.
The surviving members of the royal family
mess up to discuss whether or not this
woman deserve to receive the
inheritance of the seminal family.
In the end,
they came to a vote and decided that there
was not enough evidence to prove that
she was the real.
Anastasia has.
Supporters were shocked
because they really felt that
she was the true princess.
Grendel,
Xenia,
Alexandra [inaudible] sister of saw
Nicholas the second and Anastasia zones,
right.
That she was outraged by this decision
and that the remaining family was simply
just greedy for the friends
and family who believed to.
They felt very sorry for this disowned
princess and wanted to do whatever they
could to help out.
She lives a life of luxury
and she was given anything.
She could have a once.
She eventually moved to New
York with a woman named Annie,
but Jennings,
where she was able to live
in a gorgeous penthouse.
She changed the names.
You nrn doesn't.
She met a man named Jack Manhattan,
who was a history teacher
in Virginia that have doubt,
a very happy life together
in the United States.
Ms Dot Anderson went to a grave
claiming that she was grand,
was on a stage young
after the fall of the
Soviet Union in 1990.
One historian searched for the
bodies of the Romanov family.
After confirming their identity is
through DNA tests with surviving relatives
that were given a proper burial and the
son Peter and Paul Cathedral in Saint
Petersburg and canonized a saint in 1998.
However,
the bodies of Alexi and under you,
we're missing this was enough
to further fuel the debate.
So now we have the question.
That of course is in your mind,
and that's whether Anna Anderson
was actually Anastasia off to rule.
This inspired several movies and plays
including the 1997 animated movie
Anastasia and 2007.
The bones of two human bodies were
found buried in the middle of the woods
inside area one,
it was a male and the female,
the bones showed signs of being doused
with acid and burned by fire as well.
It was finally confirmed through DNA
testing that these were the missing bodies
of anesthesia and Alexi.
According to records
and forensic evidence,
scientists and historians now believe
that the men who killed the Romanovs
attempted to burn the bodies,
but started off with the two
smallest Alexi under anesthesia.
They covered the bones in sulfuric
acid and then set them on fire.
When they discovered that this did
not completely destroy the evidence,
they decided to move along and it's
buried the rest of the body's elsewhere.
This is why the two children had been
separated from the rest of their family.
As for Anna Anderson,
she was dead years before the
truth of her identity was revealed.
It sounds out that she was
a Polish factory worker.
She was married and work
together with her husband.
One day a grenade was tossed
into the factory and exploded.
She had to witness the love of her life
and several coworkers dying around her
before receiving a severe
head injury I bought.
He was scarred from the
shrapnel of the explosion.
After recovering from her wounds,
she had no family,
no friends to help at home.
She somehow managed to make it to Germany,
which is where the police found her,
and as they say,
the rest is history.
After revealing the truth of our identity,
many people began to call and
around us and a fraud and Delilah.
She was able to live a life of total
luxury and many considered to simply be a
very skilled con women.
However,
it's very possible that in a mental
state she may have actually believed that
she was the real Anastasia.
Before she was discovered
in the mental hospital.
She was a young woman who
had nothing left to live for.
She was ready to take her own life,
but becoming.
Anastasia gave her an identity,
a purpose,
and a family who loved her,
for the people who desperately needed
to regain that faith in humanity.
They needed to believe the innocent
children had survived the slaughter in our
own way and around us and gave them a
reason to believe in miracles from what we
know about the real Anastasia.
She lived to make people smile if she
knew that her memory and even the mere
possibility of being alive brought so
much hope and joy to so many people,
she would surely have been proud.
So I really hope you found
that video interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below
and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just
like this every day of the week.
If you look for something else right now,
why not check out my podcast?
It's called brain food.
You can find on itunes or
wherever you get your podcasts.
Just search one word.
It's kind of like we do a longer form.
Look into interesting bits and pieces
from history and the present day.
Find the link below,
like I say,
or just search brain food
one words and as always,
thank you for watching.
Mm.